So, when we first started hiring people,
I had the idea
that really the only important thing
was that I get the smartest person
to hire for the job,
and that actually turned out to be wrong
because in practice
it matters so much
whether the person that you hire
fits in well with the team,
knows how to work with other people.
You can get people who are really brilliant
but still manage to pull down the performance
of everyone else around them,
and so I gradually started looking
more and more toward social skills and initiative
and these kinds of soft skills
that didn't seem as important in the beginning
but actually turn out to make a huge difference
in how people perform on the job.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see you questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.